[Music]
this week we've got smelly kimchi shitty
fight quack honks take away Sydney
alright so in order to promote kimchi
worldwide Korean scientists are trying
to figure out create people a scientist
that's crazy yeah you need to get rid of
smell of kimchi
what's wrong with the smell of potential
of the smell I didn't know it smelled
bad okay so you want like people who are
not used to seeing it
kimchi though it's pretty [ __ ]
popular now man dude like white people
have it in the fridge your white people
have a separate kimchi for itself
they do not sure I know what came to use
it very well
oh please you all do but you guys if you
don't know what kimchi is what it looks
like would you like to explain with me a
fermented cabbage with like fish sauce
sea salt chilli paste Chili Peppers
paprika all the stuff and sounds
delicious
yeah traditionally people in Korea
because we didn't have any refrigeration
we will put an earthen pot put it in the
buried under underneath the ground so
you could eat it whenever so we will
keep it cool and so fermentation was a
way for us to eat food when when you
couldn't have cabbage anymore so you
would ferment it and you eat it
throughout this that's the way they got
variations do the other radishes yeah
pickled stuff yeah we went to Korea
they're like we're going to take you to
this traditional Korean restaurant and
then I was like cool and it was like all
these pickled side dishes and rice and
then this like soup I was like so when
the winds the meat coming out kind of
like nah this is it this is the
traditional stuff and I was like a
Porsche [ __ ] oh she's a lot of portable
food Rey like this is all is all poor
people who have to go buy a protein bar
afterwards what makes sense though it's
like how are you going to get fish or
fork or whatever in the middle of winter
you probably ate it all up it's an Asian
thing to them like like Asian like
Eastern diet like usually proteins are
used as flavoring well yeah that's like
a main dish like another nice entree is
an American
Western thing so if you look at a lot of
a specifically cream food to like fish
is used to flavor the broth the stock
and every now and then you would have
poor or whatever whatnot which was for
bigger occasions because you have to
slaughter that animal and then everybody
would eat it versus having to that's why
you have like bone marrow soup you take
that and you make soup out of it so it's
something that people use to eat with
their food not as a main thing that's so
true I'm mouths watering only the rich
people could afford lean meat and in the
Cal didn't get introduced to Asia until
like the 1600s or something like that
I forget Cal me Asia Asia meat cap it is
pretty weighted because there was a
study or there's a lot of studies right
now like in Asia because of like Western
diet and like the thought that you
always need an exorbitant amount of
protein like heart disease obesity
everything shot up like a ridiculous
amount like in some countries like China
and Korea so Asians are becoming bigger
to now because of the protein
consumption Giants do a disgusting the
giant you know it's disgusting yeah so
the scientists at the world Institute of
kimchi what I want to go there
yeah it established that the world
Institute of kimchi yeah probably may
have like two museums that are like
dedicated to kimchi you and Don Korea
must be boring as far as legit job title
is kimchi expert yeah professor of
kimchi that's what makes it Korean
though I mean it's like kimchi and I
mean you can't just have rice with stuff
it's like if you put kimchi there then
you know it's really Korean we love
kimchi this much [ __ ] dude I love
Koreans I eat kimchi was like every
single meal right every single everybody
loves my dad actually doesn't like it
which is so weird
why mom makes it my mom makes it because
I like it and my brother likes it and
then but my dad doesn't actually like
kimchi and I'd only realized that
recently and because he was she never
ate it I just noticed it when they're
like dad no he keeps you any those that
yes laughs women I know it's like you
found out my secret know it's like
Mexicans
liking tortillas yeah the cents but can
she have so many different variations
you have like Mugen Chi which is the one
that's put in Megan G you [ __ ] you know
there's a there's like kimchi that
people ferment for like years like I'm
talking about like five six Wow does
that make it taste better it's really
strongest a lot more soft and there's a
way to do it to where doesn't become
mush but I've had like when those
fermented for ten years
whoa she's expensive but it smells like
a athlete's foot sock
it's pretty [ __ ] bombs oh yeah you're
a lot of Korean families have a specific
fridge oh yeah actually smells like a
mother folks yeah so because of that
reason like because of the the intense
pungent smell of kimchi like the
scientists are trying to figure out a
way to get rid of that how do we make it
not stinky yeah cuz they go to globalize
everything just like kombucha and almost
like new stuff such like a trend in fad
but they're saying that slowly kimchi is
like spreading throughout the US but
they're trying to make it more
accessible to people because the smell
really did what is it wanted it smell
the else I used to another like it's
like this garlicky fish sauce I think
that's what it is really I don't smell
fish it's weird because you don't need
globalization for [ __ ] Parmesan
cheese and actually smells like toe
fungus it's pretty nice you know that
means so I don't think it's really
necessary I think people just have to
understand the food and then they'll
like exactly but what they're trying to
do is they're kind of fast forward the
process by making it edible to everyone
that's exactly what critics are saying
like they're like why are you trying to
get rid of the smell like people need to
learn the culture learn what learn what
they're eating rather than like and the
kick is trying to get rid of the smell
yeah they're trying to figure out a way
to engineer it so it will smell as bad
but they're saying that's hard because
the smell is the flavor like that leaves
the [ __ ] flavor you should give that
smell a lot of fun dude I should smell
hobo real yeah we got a [ __ ] Sweden
Russia snow or blue cheese you know blue
cheese or just any kind of [ __ ]
cheese that comes in a big cheap smells
like [ __ ] toast wet toast what a
bubble you are not an interesting fact
that I learned reading this article what
Koreans eat 50 cent pounds of kimchi a
year Wow probably more than that
57 I don't like you know promoting the
benefits the health benefits is can't
you psych probiotics yes sir
fiber Koreans do have a really high rate
of stomach cancer that might be because
of the alcohol in the cigars like high
sodium content in the kimchi as well
yeah I think in eastern Asian food
there's like high sodium so everyone has
like different diseases so if you're
East Asian but you grew up in the US you
have the same like heart disease
whatever but then out there it's like
all the salt high salt content so that
pretty people don't read water and
should use it in the dojo so doing
kimchi all the time with died on the
cover of their soldier bottle yeah he's
still under I guess I don't even reach
out a [ __ ] about let me work for you
Thunder well fire next time there is
this USD strawweight writer what the
hell's wrong way is his line is the like
the lightest bucket like 90 pounds is
that like a child fight what is that 100
pounds the want a between 116 to 125 oh
wow Dean yeah sure all wait that would
have been me in high school
it's like Jason Chen and David Choi
fighting each other I feel like even
then they're not they're not they're not
even you guys are probably walking
around one-30 the park cut i 130-140
my car like can Jenna Olga Cantus can
and Brad Academy choice yeah most boring
it's my ha ha ha ha - nice and I otter
there's like you hit me first no you hit
me first
yes hi I do this different you're
Superman yes no I'm he's - fine how
about we fight like this hug each other
yeah I don't know
except there's like gasping arms ha ha
ha ha they respect each other so they're
skinny as these two fighters named
Justine Kish and Felice Herrig
so in the middle of their fights just
seen accidentally desiccated we go girls
girl that's right we flee the school
[ __ ]
I thought that's why there's that way
class all right how many guys are there
that are one task [ __ ] crazy
she literally get the budget punched out
of her we were on the FLIR on villages
on ground energy the other gonna be like
I beat the [ __ ] out of her literally I
was Phil on it why did she do that I
beat the [ __ ] out of her there was so
much proof okay ready yeah she probably
had a go since wrong one you're on the
bottom whoo everywhere beat the [ __ ] out
of her
that's [ __ ] nasty give up you pulled
yourself all mine she has a diarrhea
that morning oh that's not blood baby
ah that's the blood that doodle baby
human poo [ __ ] smells like [ __ ] too
and they didn't know that she shat I
like highly saturated the footage so we
can see it even more Thank You they just
said that they just probably smelled
[ __ ] you know when you're fighting you
just I could smell it right now yeah the
guy the girl that's on top is very
committed I want to stop right away that
is what you talk about every weapon she
well there is this is million you
imagine being a [ __ ] stokehold like
you just find like a [ __ ] and
there's just do fly all over the place
feel like I got land whether I find
cheap good I would have just literally
if that was me as a person I was like
grappling with took a [ __ ] I would throw
up and he would tap just from the bar
joke it's a barf Cho we didn't keep the
man when he's down dude I know shat
himself now you get rid of all minute is
enough this is the first time this has
ever happened it seems like this will
happen a lot I think if I had to take a
poo when somebody's choking me out I
would tap
immediately because I don't want to go
down in history somebody got choked out
invention itself I'd rather just shake a
lot yeah why didn't you just take a [ __ ]
before the fight that's what I would've
done
I wonder if it's like she got knocked
through up punch so hard
started spilling yeah she can control
her mouth I don't know I mean she had
Indian food and that was just the Indian
food does that to you sometimes or it
could have been a shart you know she was
like just a tional that out of art
painting so that's me but that's a lot
it's a lot of poops off so this is do
like soccer moms or hell applause which
runs the pooper she's going that just
games the pooper
hot did she's scary looking how long
your version of heart has come down
sandy was interviewing her after the
fight and they were trying to ask her
like hey so you know what are your
thoughts on that and she was like you
know what like I like to seem like we
get along like I don't I just don't want
to watch it I wanna talk [ __ ] yeah but
then Justine she made fun of it she
didn't like what you have to say for
herself said I am a warrior and I will
never quit hashtag [ __ ] happens how I
have feedback that's a good way to
handle it did she lose a fight - she did
oh she was away in the [ __ ] be better
than this like I lost a fight but I took
a [ __ ] on myself it was like a I had to
do what I had to do to win yeah but why
did you [ __ ] yourself in the defense
mechanism Jason Thomas come imagine it
was her defense mechanism like she's
like I got it
it didn't work though way better than me
technically and strong strength eyes it
might not even be in the rule books to
be illegal because no one's ever done it
before yeah we should be like you never
told me oh that's smart if I'm on top of
it I just piss all the boys what the
[ __ ] get their guard up and you start
knocking them out lately I fart all the
time during sparring David the urinal
that's gonna fill my I'd call that if
the ladies are pissing on them it's
David golden showers oh I've never lost
the match eighty-six matches that one
pissing on people you really should add
this into the rulebook
I don't know how I would deal with that
but then like I guess when I am sparring
though I feel like relaxed or whatever
and then like I forget because I'm so
used to just farting I forget like oh
should I be polite right now nah it's
like I don't want to be thinking about
the fart that I'm holding in I want to
just spar so I just let it rip yeah and
I see the look on the guy's face and I'm
just like I did a [ __ ] know what if you
end up shooting or something I don't
know because I did shart twice remember
yeah used to shart something happened to
me got it done just to relax you use the
heart of the distraction that's it it's
like oh you'll be like detergents for
could if someone farted while we were
sparring I would question them I would
be like you farted distraction you can't
help select a seven-year-old testicle I
use fire that would be like a firework
on honking how you hear it first when
you see it that's not awesome movie
alright so for our last story
researchers suggest that we should
replace car horns with horn horn
what's up son moment hon communists are
saying horn yeah aren't you you don't
you [ __ ] [ __ ] cat named Tom horns so
they wanna replace the honk you win
that's quack oh yeah oh there we go -
yeah only you can use it with a
semi-truck awesome
yeah so there are these researchers in
South Korea that they thought they had
gotta be Asian I know yeah that's
adorable
oh yeah and you say that you like the
most gangster person writing like super
low and he puts his voice
as they got a hundred volunteers and
then they show them a lot of different
sounds and then they found that this
duck quacks we're the most effective and
alerting someone of danger and not
touching them on twisting everybody else
around but that's irrelevant because
once that becomes a standard for
everybody else then that becomes moot
yeah they're the only reason why that
works is because it's in comparison to
what's used now so everybody use that
then that's just going to be just as
annoying that's like we need to set your
favorite song as your alarm in the
morning oh and you shoot it afterwards
yeah gonna be so funny if someone has
road rage and they're like hey you
[ __ ] [ __ ] get the [ __ ]
off the road and I think like road rage
might like to plead after this movie
hilarious I can't be getting seriously
this I think you'll see Brielle I think
I'll decrease because the sound is just
less offensive but then like David said
I think it's going to decrease a little
bit it's going to hit another plateau
yeah and we should just have our option
of like different animal sounds to use
if yours would be a rooster yes I want a
cap would I be monkey with your case you
glasses off what's yours Joe ah it's a
Howlin wolf um I was cool I just thought
flamboyant gay guy skills excuse me and
Phoebe and if you hold it really long
really really good oh yeah about your
blinkers on
the blicket I have no idea what about
click clack click clack click clack
click clack that'll be no oh I want to
buy the more you can thank people you
like they let you into but you're not
positive have one where there's a bunch
of wager to communicate and it's like
horns but it's like the be careful horn
you have the Thank You horn you have all
these other stuff I'll be cool mhmmm
you've got a plea record it you just
kind of figure it out like when it
happens you're just like what button I
thought somebody with the LED in the
back of their life Subaru and it was
like a smiley face oh [ __ ] I want to
hold one of the marquee in the back of
mine yeah so if I like if someone pisses
me off in the back nice look [ __ ] you
when I'm going to pipe it into camp or
serious [ __ ] you and then shows up in
the back to be all tomorrow night you
know I was younger I always wish that it
was some sort of technology where we can
like communicate with other people's
radios so then they could hear us so we
can do like actual like messages but
through the radio that's I will [ __ ]
Moran for cutting-edge I swear to [ __ ]
yeah nice and be like no big fine where
you [ __ ] live and I'm going to
[ __ ] destroy your family Liam Neeson
style
we're like someone leaves their trunk
open oh my god I wish I could just push
that by and excuse me look for trunk
open
I think it was going to be a lot more
rhythm that not gonna use it for nice
stuff you know it's only Japanese people
they're probably gonna use it to hit on
girls
yes that was think people and five troll
I was on the 10 freeway right here it
was like like bumper bumper traffic and
some guy next to me
Mexican dude he was you're the one which
is the one who goes no what no and then
for like the next 20 minutes you think
right next to me yeah yeah even if
they're like you're like we know you
made awkward now you mean awkward other
side that had the manners to do that
than other ones that I've experienced
just don't stop
they're like no oh really in an escape
are you gay or something or what do it
even more
you'd be like oh you don't like me
harassing you let me her ask you some
more that's persistence I like that I
know good guys great quality you know
they're determined yeah yeah what if we
end up warrants but they were judging by
like a park with the lake and there's a
bunch of ducks already the Ducks are
[ __ ] your carcass got horny because
it's like a mating call that they
recorded they all personally start
attacking your corn chicken you're
humping your cousin to be like oh yeah
mating call I hope you guys enjoyed this
video for more please subscribe to our
Channel and you can check out the last
video right here
[Music]
you